toujours sur nous ces gars prennent cette
personne tu n'étais censé créer
qu'une diversion Roman qui était une
destruction complète ce que tu veux de moi je suis
Roman Pearce mec c'est ce que je fais
phase deux phase deux ce qui est en phase deux
livres Saints
tu sais quoi  J'aime ton chien,
tu es un véritable hors-la-loi, mais tu es sa
famille, un sacré travail, frère
quand nous revenons à la base des bières sur moi,
il est sur le point de se heurter à la seule
chose qu'ils ne peuvent pas gérer.
Je pense que tu trahirais ta famille comme
tu l'as fait aujourd'hui.
maintenant elle travaille avec ton gars je pense que
j'ai trouvé mon équipe ça devrait être
intéressant
on est comme
ça c'est
impossible c'est pourquoi ils vont avoir besoin d'un peu d'
aide je vais te battre comme un
tambour Cherokee on est sur le point d'y aller oh ça a pris plus de temps
que ce à quoi je m'attendais si tu vas attraper l'
aube, tu g  vous allez travailler ensemble
surprise je suis juste tombé amoureux
j'attendais ça nous avons un tank
roulons ici ils viennent je ne sais pas
le vieux Dom est là je m'en
fous je t'emmène  vers le bas alors bon d'accord
jouons à l'
usine me trompe je ne sais pas
peut-être parce que tu es une [ __ ] Lamborghini orange
-
choisis Blasco ouais nous sommes sur le point de
continuer comme oh merde
nous allons avoir besoin d'un plus gros
camion  tu vas tourner le dos à ta
famille
[Musique]